-As you guys know,
we're always striving
to get better here at
"The Tonight Show."
♪ Harder, better,
faster, stronger ♪
[ Laughter ]
So before every show,
we put out a suggestion box
for the audience just to get
some feedback about what
you guys think of the show,
things that you'd like to see us
do, that kind of stuff.
So tonight, let's look inside
the "Audience Suggestion Box."
Here we go.
-♪ Look into the box ♪
♪ The suggestion box ♪
-Okay, here we have --
The first one is from Julia Gee.
Said, "Hey, Jimmy, I'm so
excited for 'House of Gucci'
to come out this weekend.
Are you going to go see it?"
Absolutely. I can't wait.
How about you, Quest?
-Yeah, man. I love the costumes.
Yeah.
-Yeah. How about you, Mark?
-I'll probably go. Adam Driver
is good in everything.
-Yeah, he was good. Yeah.
What about you, James?
Are you excited for
"House of Gucci"?
-Never heard of it.
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-Sorry I asked.
-Wow.
-This next one is
from Jeff Billingham.
"Hey, Jimmy,
I'm a big fan of tennis."
Oh, good. I like tennis too.
"But I don't like it when tennis
players make those loud grunts.
Please don't show me
a bunch of other sports
with tennis grunting in it.
It would just really
bum me out."
[ Laughter ]
"Just kidding.
It's opposite day."
[ Laughter ]
It's a very tricky suggestion.
Well, if it's opposite day
and you don't want to see
grunting in other sports,
here you go, bud!
[ Grunting ]
-There you go.
[ Applause ]
It's opposite day.
-Yeah.
-Alright, here we go.
Let's try one more here.
This one is from April Sing.
"Hey, Jimmy, I want to make hand
turkeys with my kids this year,
but I'm a little self-conscious
about my big hands.
Any tips?"
There's nothing wrong with
having big hands.
Bigger the turkey, the better.
To show you, we're about to make
the world's largest hand turkey.
Let's roll out the paper.
♪♪
Alright, let's set
the world record. Go ahead.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Sorry, I'm drawing your hair.
Alright. Did you get it, Hig?
Alright, you guys can get up
now.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's see what we did.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, wow!
Wow! Look at this.
It's a masterpiece.
World's largest hand turkey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just missed a couple things
just to make sure it's complete.
That is unbelievable
right there.
There you have it,
a world record.
World's largest hand turkey
right there.
I'm putting this on the fridge.
Thank you, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was fun.
We gotta call
the Guinness people.
This next one here is
from Dahlia Lopez.
"Hey, Jimmy, my favorite part of
football games
is the touchdown celebrations.
What would you do
if you scored a touchdown?"
Well, that's a good question.
You know, I'm old-fashioned.
I'd probably just go through the
classic spiking the football.
How about you, Quest?
-I kinda like a Lambeau Leap,
you know?
Where you jump into the crowd.
-Yeah, I like that.
That's a good one. Yeah.
What about you, Higs?
-I don't know. Maybe -- Maybe
something like this.
[ Grunts ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was amazing!
Higgins, that was amazing.
-Yeah, whatever.
-Wow.
Higgins, I didn't know you knew
how to catch a football.
[ Laughter ]
-I had to learn that.
I knew the break dancing.
-Yeah. Alright, last suggestion
right here.
This is from Chelsea Mitchell.
"Hey, Jimmy, I love Hallmark
Christmas movies,
but I've noticed their posters
are all really similar.
You should do some re-creations
of them."
Yeah, that's a great idea. But
I'm going to need a little help.
So here to join me in
re-creating Hallmark's Christmas
movie posters is Julie Bowen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah, now that's what I'm talking
about.
-Let's do this.
-Thank you, thank you.
I appreciate this. Yeah.
Alright.
-Let's do it. Come on.
-We're going to do many of these
as we can as fast as we can.
-Competitive dressing.
-Thank you, Steph.
Yep.
-Okay.
-Alright, here we go.
Now, the original poster
will pop up on the left.
We're going to have
to re-create it.
Are you ready to do this?
-Hell yeah.
Are we making out
in any of them?
-I don't know. I have no idea.
[ Laughter ]
Here we go. Ready?
Alright, let's do it.
And go.
Oh!
[ Ding! ]
-Oh, look at this.
Candy cane.
Oh, wrong way?
[ Applause ]
No, wrong way.
It was the wrong way.
We went the wrong way.
-No, we were right.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
-Here on this side.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We did it. We did it.
-Oh, that one?
-Oh, wait.
-Am I here?
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
-We nailed that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
I like your bland face.
-Yeah, thank you.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Dinging ]
-There you go!
We have it right there!
Thank you very much!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, wow!
Oh, who's a -- Come on.
Thank you.
-We killed it.
-The best. Thank you.
That is Julie Bowen right there.
That is all the time we have
for our suggestion box.